alliance are being drawn in the fight
over free speech in america on the side
of freedom you have the world's richest
man elon musk getting one step closer to
liberating twitter from censorship crazy
liberals the tesla ceo says he secured
more than 46 billion dollars for his
potential takeover and on the other side
you have former president barack obama
who is pushing for more censorship
online
the first amendment is a check on the
power of the state
it doesn't apply to private companies
like facebook or twitter while content
moderation
can limit the distribution of clearly
dangerous content
it doesn't go far enough now so much of
the conversation around disinformation
is focused on what people post the
bigger issue is what content
these platforms
promote
if obama gets his way get ready for more
of this according to a new study by the
media research center big tech giants
have censored biden criticism 400 and
646 times over two years i can read
um all right judge listen in in obama's
speech right talking about free speech
and disinformation and content
moderation
he never talked about the wuhan lab
never talked about hunter biden laptop
never talked about russia collusion so
all the big stories of disinformation
that we've all experienced over the
course of the last five years he didn't
mention but it's it's the steve bannons
of the world that are the real threat
you know what i find most interesting is
the timing of all of this now that we
have elon musk getting closer to taking
over twitter uh barack obama former
president of the united states comes out
and starts talking about the first
amendment and the moderation of that of
that uh that concept that is so
fundamental to who we are uh and it
makes us the freest country in the world
the first amendment the freedom to speak
the freedom to practice religion
uh and the freedom to assemble i mean
all of that is fundamental to who we are
and this concept that somehow they can
stop us from communicating and make no
mistake when we communicate by email we
years ago would have done it by mail and
now we're doing it by email and they are
looking at our communications my emails
my letters so to speak to another person
and saying you can't say that you can't
say that we're gonna take you off so you
can't repeat this this is the antithesis
of the constitution and what free speech
is all about and he what obama is doing
is he is cultivating now the concept
that we can moderate things a content
moderation and now we can get rid of
disinformation which leads us to the
place where if you don't agree with what
i think you will be shut down and we've
been battling this since you know since
since biden came in even before that
even before the election when all of a
sudden a newspaper cannot be transmitted
or tweeted or our comments about what is
in the news or 51 intelligence officers
lying and saying it's russian
disinformation are they do they think
that we're that stupid that they need to
tell us what we can and cannot read this
infuriates me he is wrong on this this
is un-american free speech is
fundamental and when we lose it we're
gone so i think it's interesting obama
there started the speech off by saying
i'm a first amendment uh fundamentalist
i mean i i i you you can't infringe on
the first amendment then you spent the
rest of the speech undermining free
speech in the whole speech the first
amendment but i hear harold i mean to
you i think it's interesting because
free speech is not about protecting
speech that we agree with free speech is
about protecting speech we disagree with
and
isn't it better that we all engage in
the arena of debate and ideas and the
best ideas will rise to the top isn't
that been the american way
without question um
i think when we say we're free speech
absolutist
we're all fudging a little bit because
the court has said you you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater uh we see a
prominent case that uh is taking place i
think between two actors on virginia
that based on libel and defamation so
there are certain things you can't say
and that the law protects that being the
case you're right sean in terms of i
want free speech i want a free debate
some of this this this harkens back a
little bit to the conversations we were
having around education and some of the
things that were being taught in schools
i think it's important that we present
ideas and may unsettle people right for
us to be able to have these
conversations and have these debates and
even if the best ideas don't rise at
least we inform and educate people about
what the issues are uh and finally we we
should not be mistaken elon musk
is pursuing this he's the richest man in
the world he sends people a space he
makes electric cars he makes batteries
uh or he buys batteries uh he's doing
this for an economic this is a guy that
knows his way around a balance sheet in
the profit sheet so at the end of the
day if there were not money to be made
doing this i doubt he would be doing it
yes and katie isn't it fair that the
founders actually believed that we
didn't want a uh a ministry of truth we
wanted to actually let the debate happen
listening to barack obama say that the
first amendment is only a check on the
state
makes me question why he wouldn't want
the first amendment to apply to big
corporations and to corporations
especially that make all of their money
on speech people being able to talk
about things but then i look back at who
president obama really is and he's a
student of solinsky and so lindsay
teaches in rules of radicals if you
control the narrative you control
information you then control the media
and you control
everything and he talked about how
you know free speech is not being able
to disseminate or post clearly dangerous
content well to the left clearly
dangerous content is things like hunter
biden's laptop it's things about the
wuhan lab it's basic things about gender
and biology and so they've shifted from
actually dangerous incitement content to
any kind of content that they deem a
risk for their political prospects and
that's why they have no credibility on
this but it i think it's highly alarming
that the president united states is
performer president is perfectly fine
with these monster corporations going
after a certain speech that he cert just
simply doesn't like and only one-sided
right greg final word well as you know
i'm an expert on the constitution
and when obama says there is
no first amendment protection on social
media platforms because they're private
he's actually right yes but it's also
wrong because these platforms have now
become the single most dominant platform
for the exchange of information right so
they aren't like
other media entities i think what he
does is he wants you to believe it's
just like fox news or the new york times
in which there is no obligation for us
to host other people's ideas this is our
show you can't come on here this is you
know [ __ ] you know you know what i'm
saying but that is not this right
denying access to facebook or to twitter
is essentially denying access to the
modern town square it's not like the new
york times it's not like any other place
i think the bigger issue which i touched
on yesterday is uh um you cannot trust
the credibility of any obvious partisan
or politician with an ideology to
moderate content because what you're
going to get is content removal that
only flows in one direction it's v you
would call it viewpoint discrimination
right it only works on behalf in this
case i think when you look at the hunter
laptop and russian collusion it seems to
only flow on behalf of the left which is
why they don't mind but if it once it
gets more balanced and let's say you do
have an elon musk take over twitter
because i think he is he is credible
because i have no idea what his politics
are i would assume he's probably a
libertarian but i don't know if he's a
republican i don't know if he's a
democrat i find that really healthy that
i don't know so once that happens and
you might see you might see viewpoint
discrimination happen in both directions
because i put out a viewpoint and then
somebody puts out a counter viewpoint
and it all shows up on twitter that's
the way it should be well and sean you'd
know this but they've been trying to
censor talk radio right now since the
90s so this is not new it's just a
different meaning but if harold and i
were able to censor our opponents when
we ran for congress the power of that
was immense we wouldn't we wouldn't have
spent any money to run races because
it's only our viewpoint this out there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else